a white house is dealing with yet
another crisis this morning officials
are denying what may be the most serious
allegation against President Trump since
he took office
fired FBI director James Comey says the
president tried to convince him to end
the investigation of former national
security adviser Michael Flynn the story
was first reported by the New York Times
and then confirmed by CBS News James
Comey wrote a memo about an oval office
meeting with the president this was the
day after general Flynn was forced to
resign
Jeff McGee's is outside FBI headquarters
in Washington Jeff good morning good
morning the Comey memos are the latest
bombshell in this still unfolding story
the former FBI director was known for
taking detailed notes of meetings but
these Comey memos allegedly show a
pattern and raise additional questions
about whether the president was trying
to interfere in the Russia investigation
and why former FBI director James Comey
--zz memo details the February 14th
meeting when he was alone in the Oval
Office with President Trump Comey says
he was asked to drop the bureau's
investigation into former national
security adviser Michael Flynn I hope
you can see your way clear to letting
this go to letting Flynn go the
president allegedly said he is a good
guy I hope you can let this go Comey
agreed Flynn is a good guy a day earlier
Flynn had resigned as national security
adviser after it was revealed he misled
the vice president about his contacts
with Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac
those contacts are now part of the FBI's
counterintelligence investigation the
White House said the president has never
asked mr. Comey or anyone else to end
any investigation this was not the only
private encounter between the two men
according to sources close to the former
director On January 27th at a White
House dinner the president asked Comey
if he would pledge his loyalty Comey
declined instead telling the president
he would always be honest the president
also denied that account
he's a showboat he's a grandstander
after director Comey was fired last week
a senior FBI official told CBS News
they had never seen this level of
interference from the White House when I
decided to just do it I said to myself I
said you know this Russia thing with
Trump and Russia is a made-up story
president Trump also denied his
administration applied pressure to the
FBI did anyone from the White House ask
him to end the investigation now why
would he did any surrogates on behalf of
the way not that I know of sources
familiar with commis actions say it was
not unusual for him to keep detailed
notes of meetings that could later be
called into question it is actually
something that the FBI trains its agents
to do Gail
all right Jeff thank you very much